every time I had a new company I was
starting I was still working at the
company I had sold the last one to and I
had permission but um I had salary and I
was plotting my next move plotting my
next company getting things set up and
then I also looked at my personal burn
and said hey let's get all these credit
cards paid off let's make sure my rent
and my I know my expenses I don't have
credit card debt I paid off my student
loans I set myself up for Success if I
was only taking a 10K draw and my
previous burn rate was was 18K a month I
got that personal burn rate down to 12K
so was only 2K different I built up my
savings to 40K and I knew I could get
through 20 months of this journey and I
had my partners buying